most developers already know that redis
is a mega fast in-memory database often
used as a cache to make traditional
databases faster but what most
developers don't know is that redis can
also be used as a primary app database
thanks to a suite of modules that add
additional data structures and commands
to core redis they can handle json data
full text search graph relationships and
many other features in today's video
we'll put this claim to the test by
building a full text autocomplete search
inspired by something like algolia or
elasticsearch where the user can add
items to the database and instantly view
the filtered results we'll build this
project from scratch using next.js
allowing us to use react on the front
end and nodejs to interact with redis on
the back end as an added bonus redis
just released a brand new sdk called
redis ohm that supports object mapping
and nodejs if you're new here like and
subscribe and you can follow along with
the full article on fireship io let's
first take a look at what we're building
today we have a form that when submitted
we'll add a new item to the database in
redis this data would normally be saved
as a hash data structure but a hash
doesn't support nested objects so
instead we'll be storing this data as
native json thanks to the redis json
module now after adding a few items to
the database we may want to retrieve
them later when i type into the search
form field you can see that it
automatically updates the results in the
ui after every keystroke that's made
possible by redis search which is an
incredibly powerful module that can
index all of the fields on your json
dataset at which point you can perform
complex queries like you would with the
where clause in sql and aggregations
like sum and count now we're ready to
start building there are a few different
ways you can get started with redis the
easiest option is to sign up for
rediscloud i collaborated with redis
enterprise cloud to make this video and
they're providing a 200 credit and also
a chance to win a tesla model 3 if you
use this code before january 31st so
that's pretty awesome but more
importantly redis is consistently the
most loved database out there i've used
it myself for many years and that's why
i decided to work with them on this
video after you sign in you'll be
prompted to create a new subscription go
ahead and do that and you can choose a
free fixed plan to play around once
that's done create a database and when
creating it make sure to add the add-on
modules of redis search and redis json
and you now have your own database that
can scale infinitely in the cloud to
connect to it you'll notice this public
endpoint url as well as a password for
the default user now the question
becomes how do we connect to our
database this is optional but the first
thing i would recommend doing is
downloading the redis insight tool which
gives you a gui to analyze and manage
data in the database once installed
click the option to add a new database
and then paste in the public url that
rediscloud provided you with then also
enter the username of default and the
password it generated and then it should
automatically connect to your database
the cool thing about redis is that it's
really easy to learn because everything
is organized into a set of key value
pairs here's a little crash course of
the redis basics to add a new item to
the database you create a new key every
key is unique and is used to identify a
value in the database a key can also
have a data type in this case we'll use
a string but there are more complex data
types like a hash for objects of
multiple key value pairs lists and as
we'll see later json data for now let's
go ahead and save a string with a key of
hello and a value of world it also gives
you the option to specify a ttl or time
to live after which point the data will
be automatically deleted if you want
leave it blank to keep the data forever
now the unique thing about redis is that
when you save data that data is kept in
memory as opposed to the disk like it
would be on most other traditional
database systems what that means is that
redis is extremely fast there's no need
for a round trip to the disk when
retrieving data but on redis cloud this
data is also persisted which means
there's never any actual data loss now
to make a read to the database let's go
over to the workbench panel and you'll
notice a terminal here where we can
write commands redis has a bunch of
built-in commands that allow us to do
different things in the database for
example what we just did previously was
a set with a command it would look like
set followed by hello world now to read
the string we can use the get command
followed by the key name of hello now
there are tons of other commands we
could execute here to interact with our
data but that's enough to give you the
general idea now we're ready to build
something cool and in order to do that
we'll want to first initialize next js
from the command line run npx create
next app then open it up in vs code the
project has only one dependency redis om
which you can install with npm this
library is brand new so keep in mind
that there may be changes or
enhancements in the near future what it
does is map your data into a javascript
class or entity making it really easy to
build a consistent schema around your
data and it simplifies many of the
create read update and delete operations
that you'll want to do on the database
first we'll need to connect to our cloud
database and for that i'm creating a
file
called.env.local that contains
environment variables that will
automatically be picked up by next.js
inside of it we have a value of redis
url which is formatted with the username
and password along with the url and port
of the actual database replace these
values with the ones provided by redis
cloud now from there let's create a lib
directory and a file named redis.js
inside the file we have a few imports
from redisome the first one we want to
think about is the client that's the
main entry point for interacting with
the database to connect to our database
in the cloud we call client open
followed by process.env.redisurl
that will access the environment
variable that we set up earlier now
because of the way next.js works i'm
also going to create an async function
called connect that will only open the
connection if it's not already open then
the next thing we'll do is define an
entity for our data an entity is
basically like a database table we first
define a class like car and extend it
with entity from there we can give it a
schema that contains a variety of
different properties each with its own
specific data type by default this
represents a hash in the redis database
however when building a more traditional
application you might find it easier to
work with json to use the redis json
module simply add the option of data
structure json and now redis will
operate more like a document oriented
database now that we have this entity
we're ready to start creating data to
handle the basic process i'm going to
export an async function here called
create car and then the first thing it
does in the body is connect to the
database client from there we create a
repository by combining the schema and
the client together if we want to create
new data we can use the create entity
method with a javascript object which
later we'll get from a form input in the
ui and lastly we can call repository
save with the card data to commit it to
the database and redis will return an
automatically generated unique id the
key is car colon unique id then the
value is json data with the schema that
you defined now the question becomes how
do we run this function for that we'll
need two things we need an api route
which will give a name of cars.js to
handle the right operation on the back
end then we'll need a react component
which i'll give a name of carforum.js in
the lib directory that will handle the
user input and make a request to that
api route let's first implement the api
route we first import the createcar
function we just defined then every api
route in next exports a default function
named handler which contains a request
and response where the request is the
incoming data and the response is the
outgoing data you want to send back to
the client in this case we'll want to
use the request body which will be json
data from the form to create a new car
once redis is done writing that data we
can then send a response back to the
client letting them know it was
successful with the new unique id now
that we have an api endpoint we want to
call it from the front end when a form
is submitted in carform.js i have a
react component and in the jsx we have a
standard html form with a few different
text inputs it also has a submit button
and we will intercept the submit event
by passing a function to the form called
handle submit in the handle submit
function we'll first call event prevent
default to prevent the page from
refreshing on submit and then here's a
cool trick when handling form data in a
react component normally to convert the
form event to json you would have to
access each individual property which
leads to some really ugly and tedious
code a better approach is to convert the
event target which is the html form to
the form data class which is built into
the browser that will organize the form
fields into a bunch of key value pairs
which we can then turn into a plain
javascript object by using object from
entries now it's important to point out
that the name that you provide to the
form input determines the name of the
key so you'll want to make sure that
that name matches the schema that you
chose for your redis data now the final
step is to make a request to the api
endpoint which we can do by using the
fetch api in the browser and for the
body we pass it the json stringified
form data you'll want to make sure the
content type is json and the method is
post from there we can send the request
convert it to json and then console log
the result and now there's just one
thing left to do let's go into the
index.js file and declare the car form
there and now we can fire up the next js
app by running npm run dev in the ui you
should have a form that looks like this
mine looks a little prettier because
i've added bootstrap for styling and
when you fill it out and submit it it
should console log the id that was
created by redis in addition you should
be able to open up redis inside to see
the data there as well at this point we
have a very basic full stack application
with redis now you might be wondering
how do i query and filter this data to
show it on the front end that's where
redis search comes in it's a very
powerful module that allows you to index
and search across your data set to use
it though we first need to create an
index and to do that i'm going to go
back into the redis.js file and create a
new function called createindex all this
function needs to do is reference the
repository and call the createindex
method now before we use this function
another thing i want to point out is
that we can go up into our schema and
add a text search true option to any
fields that want to enable full text
search what this allows us to do is
query this data with fuzzy matching
where it can recognize typos and common
words yet still return the intended
result let's go ahead and add the full
text option to the description now
creating the index is only something you
need to do once for convenience i'm
going to add another api route here
called create index that imports that
function and then sends a response back
once defined we can then go to the
browser and access the url api create
index to add the index to the database
now that we have an index let's go back
to the redis.js file and create a
function to search for cars in the
database this function will take a query
as its input which will be whatever the
user types into the form and then it
calls the repository search method which
has all kinds of different capabilities
like pagination it can retrieve the
first and last items it can get a count
of the total items in the database and
also perform logical comparisons like
greater than less than and so on the
first method to call is where which
references one of the properties in the
json data in this case we can search the
make of the car for exact equality with
the eq method and pass it the query as
an argument if we also want to search
the model of the car at the same time we
can chain or model and also check that
for equality now when it comes to the
description we don't want exact equality
but instead we want to check the matches
within a full text search context that
tells it to return results even if there
are typos and things like that and
finally we tell it to return all the
results from that query that takes care
of the search logic now once again we
need an api route which we can easily
set up by adding a search.js file inside
of which we export a handler it'll grab
the search query from the url called the
searchcars method and then return the
response which will be an array of cars
back to the client and now the last
thing we need is a form on the front end
to make calls to the search endpoint i'm
creating a new file called searchform.js
which is a react component and in the
jsx we have an input that triggers a
search function whenever it is changed
so that'll fire whenever the user types
into the form now this component will
also need to have state to represent the
hits or results that we get back from
the search engine we can define that
state with the use state hook and
initialize it as an empty array in the
search function we will first grab the
current value of the form and then
format it as a url parameter the api
route is expecting it in that format to
pass the value along to redis now you'll
also notice that i'm only going to
execute this code if the query length is
greater than 2. that's just to prevent
excessive api calls to the database or
api route it would also be a good idea
to debounce this code because currently
it will make an api call for every
keystroke and that's probably more api
calls than you actually need for
something like this from there we can
use the fetch api to make a request to
the search endpoint along with the
parameters the result we get back will
be an array of cars that we can set as
the state on this component now let's
display the card data by setting up an
unordered list then map each individual
hit to a list item i'm using the entity
id as the key and then displaying
whatever data i want to show in the ui
like the make and model and image of the
car congratulations you just built a
full stack full text search feature with
redis and next js i'm going to go ahead
and wrap things up there if you want to
see more redis or next js content let me
know in the comments thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one